- [Kelly] It's nice to meet
you, I'm such a big fan.
- It's so good to meet
you, too. Thank you.
- One day, I'm gonna hug you
and it's gonna be so inappropriately long.
(Joseph laughs)
Like, I'm, 'cause I love hugging.
- Making up for lost time.
- I know. And I'm just
seriously as such a big fan.
I think you're so gifted.
I was so excited you're on the show.
- Thank you, that's nice.
- And I love you on "Lip Sync
Battle," you're hilarious.
(Joseph laughs)
But what does Axl Rose sound like?
Give us a taste. I hear you do Axl Rose.
- You know, they were asking me back,
they were, like, "Have
you ever met Kelly?"
I was like,
"We haven't met, but I sang
'Since You've Been Gone'
as Axl Rose on 'The
Tonight Show' one time."
And they're like, "Oh,
you have to do Axl Rose."
I'm like, "That was 10
years ago, I did Axl Rose
on 'The Tonight Show,' I'm a dad now."
And they're like, "So sing a dad song."
I was, like-
- We are still cool as parents.
- Absolutely.
(Kelly laughs)
Watch this. Okay.
I'm gonna do a dad song as Axl Rose.
Hold on. Can I get a microphone?
Can I, like, oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yes! Yes!
(audience cheers)
- Gotta feel it.
(Kelly groans)
(Joseph clears throat)
- Oh, my God.
(Kelly coughs)
- Ready?
- Love you.
♪ Twinkle twinkle little star ♪
♪ How I wonder what you are, yeah ♪
(audience cheers)
(Kelly claps)
- Oh, my God.
- Cool as parents, right?
- I loved it.
You have to get the thing there ...
- You're, right? The side-
- The sides in your-
- It's true.
- And the bandana.
I love it.
So wait, does it hurt
your throat to do that?
- Oh yeah. I'm not gonna be able to talk
for like a week now.
I don't know how that guy
would sing whole concert.
- Oh my God. It's like, that's my thing.
I love Chris Stapleton, too.
He's one of my favorite
singers on the planet.
And I'm like,
"How do you have a voice?
Like, your voice is so raspy,"
but some people are born like,
and some people just
smoke and drink a lot.
(Joseph laughs)
But, I think that happens, too.
Okay, so I know we just met,
but I have another request for you
because I heard that
you speak French with,
I think is so cool and sexy-
- [Joseph] Oh, really?
- But I want to know what a
French Axl Rose sounds like.
(Joseph laughs)
- Now Axl Rose in French.
What would he say?
- Something sexy.
(speaks French)
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applauds)
- Oh, my God, I love
that you speak French.
Do you speak any other languages?
- I mean, I can (speaks Spanish).
- Okay, like the Latin-based ones? Yeah.
- Well, I mean, I grew up in LA, you know,
but like the high school I
went to more kids, you know,
grew up speaking Spanish
than English, you know?
- Yeah.
- So I wish that I spoke
Spanish better, to be honest,
it's always been-
- I thought that was pretty cool.
- I can, like, I've got my, you know,
my lines in my pocket
that I can, like, say,
you know what I mean?
I just said like,
"Oh, I understand better
than I speak in Spanish,"
so that's, like, my signal.
- That's my thing. Okay.
I impress the owl on Duolingo
'cause I play Duolingo-
- Duolingo is fun.
- He will shame you, that owl.
But if you quit doing it for a while,
but it's one of those
things I find so impressive
because when you go, like, overseas,
everybody speaks so many languages.
- I know, it's true.
- And, like, here, usually,
maybe two, but usually just one.
I think it's so impressive.
- I think it changes your mind
when you speak in another language,
because your language defines
how you think, you know?
So when you can speak another language,
it's not just being able
to say the same things.
You, like, you think of things differently
when you can think in
a different language.
- I love that.